los buenos precios de las materias
primas le dan una especie de respiro a
la región de suramérica con esto
comenzamos a economía en france24 está
conmigo en el estudio daniel hablando
con daniela muy buenas noches un respiro
para la región entonces aquí de santiago
muy buenas noches para que vea que no
sólo son malas noticias en esta región
el repunte de los precios de los
commodities que van desde alimentos
hasta los materiales más necesarios para
la fabricación de tecnología es hoy una
bala de oxígeno para una región
duramente golpeada por el cob y 19
suramérica es proveedora santiago de un
gran abanico de materias primas
argentina brasil y uruguay son grandes
productores de soja cuyo precio casi se
ha duplicado en apenas un año también
son de carne por el lado de los metales
el punto histórico del cobre que hoy
superó el récord que había logrado hace
una década beneficia a perú y a chile
este último el mayor productor del mundo
por otro lado el litio del que bolivia
tiene una de las mayores reservas
también subió y el precio del petróleo
está llegando a los 70 dólares por
barril una buena noticia para colombi
y para venezuela la razón de todo
santiago la pandemia generó una
interrupción de la oferta y después una
demanda acumulada de productos y a eso
se suman otros procesos como el de
descarbonización que impulsan la
búsqueda de metales muchos de ellos
presentes en esta región bueno un
respiro una válvula de oxígeno para
nosotros hablemos ahora de la ocde que
presentó hoy un estudio sobre el impacto
económico del consumo de alcohol
santiago el club de países ricos primero
llama la atención sobre un interesante
dato anótelo se estima que 3 de cada 10
adultos en sus países miembros toma
hasta emborracharse al menos una vez al
mes y esto tiene consecuencias
económicas desde luego el organismo dice
que las enfermedades por consumo de
alcohol llevan un 24 por ciento del
gasto total en salud anual también que
en los próximos 30 años el pib de sus
países miembros será 1,6 por ciento más
bajo por el mismo motivo también envía
un mensaje a los gobiernos por cada
dólar que inviertan en prevenir el
consumo nocivo se devuelven hasta 16
dólares en beneficios económicos el
problema se agudizó
en pandemia porque subió el consumo en
especial en australia bélgica francia
reino unido y eeuu seguimos hablando de
la ocde porque costa rica este país de
centroamérica busca entrar en ese club
por habilidad a costa rica si pues el
congreso aprobó la adhesión que
convertiría a costa rica en el miembro
número 38 del grupo de países con
mejores prácticas en políticas públicas
si hablamos sólo de latinoamérica este
país centroamericano sería el cuarto en
ingresar al selecto grupo después de
chile méxico y colombia pero el proceso
no es fácil costa rica comenzó trámites
desde que laura chinchilla era
presidente hace una década y recibió la
invitación apenas en 2020 ahora está
pendiente llevar la propuesta de
adhesión a francia que es la sede del
organismo pregúntele a colombia cuánto
se demora suerte entonces para los
costarricenses un largo camino todavía
se desplomó el precio del beat coin a
nivel mundial daniela cuéntame porque
ella explíqueme por qué
la divisa más cotizada cuesta unos 37
mil 800 dólares lejos de los 60 mil
dólares que costaba en abril cuando
llegó a máximo histórico- sólo el
miércoles cayó en 13% por varias razones
primero el banco central chino decidió
no aceptar los tokens digitales como
medio de pago a pesar de que el proyecto
para introducir su propio joan digital
está bastante adelantado por su parte el
banco central europeo volvió a tachar el
bitcoin de arriesgado y especulativo y
advirtió que deja una exorbitante huella
de carbono para el planeta pero hay un
tercer factor escuchemos cuál es
y esto se debe a un cambio de sentido de
él en moscú quien ha sido uno de los
mayores defensores de bitcoin y las
cripto monedas y dice que ahora tesla no
aceptará transacciones en bitcoin para
sus autos hace tres meses dijo que lo
haría así que es un gran cambio de
imagen un movimiento que conmocionó el
sistema de las cripto monedas que aclaró
daniel hablemos ahora de los indicadores
la bolsa de nueva york que reaccionó con
pérdidas a la publicación de las actas
de la más reciente junta de la reserva
federal
las acciones europeas marcaron su peor
día en una semana por las preocupaciones
sobre mayor inflación y américa latina
cerró en negativo santiago y cifra del
día 39,4 por cierto en esta cifra se
ubicó la pobreza laboral en méxico en el
primer trimestre de 2021 este es el
porcentaje de la población cuyo ingreso
no le alcanza para cubrir la canasta
básica alimentaria gracias daniela por
esta actualización es toda la economía
en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]